the edgy kids who make up the DC
extended universe is Suicide Squad are a
far cry from the comics original team of
straight-laced heroes while the original
crew simply strove for the benefit of
mankind the modern squads interests are
generally a bit more unpredictable which
is not to say that the Suicide Squad
hasn't always been filled with a fair
dose of crazy here's a look at the
squad's weird history origins secret
origins number 14 reveals that squadron
s was where the army put all of their
crazier soldiers who would either get
the job done or kill each other the crew
took the name Suicide Squad not because
they were willing to die but because
most soldiers would rather kill
themselves than join squadron s the
dysfunctional team is headed up by Rick
Flagg senior and they're called into
action to fight super threats after the
Justice Society of America temporarily
quits much later Rick Flagg jr. takes
over his dad's legacy after Rick's
senior kills himself fighting the war
wheel while still in mourning for his
deceased wife flag Jr's team first
appears in 1959 s the brave in the bold
number 25 colonel rick flagg jr. karen
grace jess bright and dr. hugh evans are
all the last living members of their
respective teams all willing to die to
save the world and uplift their lost
friends legacies they're basically a
crew powered by pure survivor's guilt
even in their first appearance fighting
a giant red hot dinosaur the squad makes
it clear that their event suicidal but
for all the right reasons
after about fifty issues bright and
Evans are swallowed up in an icy
crevasse while battling a Yeti the team
disbands and the two are assumed dead
for years
bright however survives by pulling a
page right out of Star Wars and digging
himself into the warm Yeti carcass the
Chinese government eventually finds him
removes his busted body parts and uses
their own super soldier program
rescue him so they can use a scientific
genius right now angry and insane goes
on to create a terrorist supervillain
team called the jihad who flag the squad
for decades after the team disband and
reforms The Suicide Squad again becomes
the repository for the unwanted but
instead of just really bad soldiers
Flagg jr. has to manage semi reformed
supervillains the squad is a great place
for DC Comics to put their stranger
villains digging up obscure comic
history along the way Harley Quinn dr.
Harleen Quinzel entered DC Comics as an
under qualified Arkham Asylum
psychiatrist who falls under the Joker's
grosse spell she became a fan favorite
villain pretty quickly but most readers
seemed to just ignore the fact that the
Joker has tried to kill Harley more
times than her enemies ever have despite
regular abuse her infatuation with the
Clown Prince of Crime continued for
about two decades until her writers
realized that depicting an abusive
relationship as endearing wasn't really
responsible in Harley Quinn number 25
she beat the Joker to a pulp in his own
prison cell completely biting off his
lower lip in the process making it very
hard for him to smile that winning grin
Deadshot Floyd Lawton is an assassin
with a heart of gold and a cyborg eye
who embodied the spirit of the Suicide
Squad better than any other member he
has no wish to live refuses to commit
suicide and wants to die in an
honourable way Deadshot strangest
adventure is set off by an airport
employee who steals his costume from his
luggage and goes around killing innocent
people forcing the real Deadshot to well
shoot him dead shooting a guy dressed as
himself messes up Deadshot for a while
until he's possessed by a demon tries to
blow up some kids in an elementary
school and then tries to kill the Pope
which is probably the worst thing a
comic character has ever attempted
El Diablo the name el Diablo has
generally applied to heroic characters
in DC's history but the modern el Diablo
is first seen accidentally killing the
entire innocent family of a rival gang
member he seeks redemption by joining
the squad and frequently voices his
objections to any senseless killing
during his very first outing with the
squad the team has to contain a stadium
full of humans infected with a robo
virus that kinda turns them into zombies
when El Diablo and Deadshot are attacked
by a pregnant woman bot Diablo is the
one who protects her from being killed
she mutates into a crazy Java blob king
shark bites her head off and the team
delivers a healthy baby by slicing it
out of the monster's belly the whole
thing sets off a rivalry between Diablo
and Deadshot katana
while most of these Suicide Squad
members are part of Batman's rogues
gallery katana actually worked alongside
Batman in his team The Outsiders she
still doesn't completely fit into the
superhero model as she wields a sword
that steals Souls and heroes generally
like to leave Souls in the bodies they
came from katana sword has a pretty
special relationship with death so the
heroine was able to help stop the Black
Lantern zombies plans when they invaded
earth during the epic DC Comics events
blackest night so while carrying around
a sword full of tortured souls is a
pretty sucky superpower to have it's not
altogether useless corpse whispering is
a pretty profitable back-up plan if the
whole hero thing doesn't work out just
ask John Edward and chant hrus if you go
to a party at a creepy Castle don't
wander around or else you run the risk
of being possessed by an ancient space
witch that's just common sense
unfortunately June moon didn't get the
memo now she plays host to a powerful
evil that she can only sometimes control
causing her to unpredictably split
between hero and villain after a while
the forces that gave enchantress her
powers went rotten so she turned crazy
and attacked Supergirl earning her new
villain status enchantress has been
separated from and reunited with the
Dark Soul that fuels her a few times
leaving her catatonic or tucked safely
away in an asylum so she's kind of
dammed either way all of this makes her
a pretty good candidate for the Suicide
Squad Captain Boomerang remember the
time you brought your teddy bear to
school and everyone laughed at you so
you decided to go home and become a
teddy bear themed super villain that's
pretty much the origin story of Captain
Boomerang except with boomerangs digger
Harkness is probably one of the worst
human alive in the DC Universe
he's outwardly racist he's cowardly and
he went on a pie-throwing rampage
against his teammates that lasted a year
and a half eventually everyone got so
tired of them that he was dropped on a
deserted island until the squad needed
him again
when he was picked up he'd grown a
wicked beard and was trying to build a
giant boomerang to fly himself home
because not only is he a jerk but he's
pretty stupid too his first mission back
dressing up like Batman to distract some
bad guys because captain boomerangs best
power is being a human target Killer
Croc
Waylon Jones has more origin stories
than teeth and that's a lot for a
man-eating crocodile person whether his
condition was caused by a skin disease a
gypsy curse bad steroids or genetic
experiments gone wrong croc is now a guy
who is super strong super dumb and
hungry for living meat when Batman came
nosing around he was getting closer
closer
I threw rock that in crock actually has
a special relationship with DC weirdo
Swamp Thing
at one point Swamp Thing [ __ ] crock
into breaking out of Arkham causing
Batman to pursue him all the way to
Louisiana after a battle through the
muck Swamp Thing subdues Batman with a
puff of psychotropic pollen convincing
Batman to let the animalistic croc
finally find peace and solitude in the
swamps at least for a little while
Slipknot years before the metal band of
the same name made its debut Slipknot
was a forgettable villain the bad guy is
first seen attacking DC hero firestorm
using a gimmick even worse than Captain
Boomerang boomerangs ropes sure they're
durable ropes but they're still ropes
and even though DC Comics already had
its ultimate durable rope and Wonder
Woman's lasso of truth they still needed
more ropes and that Slipknot Slipknot's
worst moment comes at the hands of
boomerang in order to keep the Suicide
Squad in check each member is fitted
with exclusive wristbands that can't go
beyond a certain range or they'll
explode
boomerang isn't keen on using himself to
test whether or not these explosive
devices are real so he convinces
Slipknot that they're fake Slipknot
takes the first opportunity to escape
only to have his arm blown off by a very
real explosive wrist bomb which makes it
pretty hard to tie Slipknot for a while
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know your favorite
Suicide Squad member